[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
nueva york- esa jungla de cemento donde
se fabrican los sueños como diría el
rapero jay si es también una de las
ciudades más caras del mundo y si
evidentemente eso incluye también el
precio de la vivienda queridos amigos
queridas amigas de visual política el
alquiler medio de un apartamento de dos
habitaciones en nuevayork asciende a dos
mil 695 dólares al mes y si esto os
parece mucho tener en cuenta que en el
período pre pandemia esa cantidad
ascendía a tres mil quinientos dólares
si es verdad hablamos de precio medio
evidentemente podrías encontrar
alternativas más económicas y también es
cierto que nueva york- los salarios son
más altos pero aún así tal y como os
podéis imaginar son precios que no
resultan aptos para todos los bolsillos
los neyorquinos de bajos ingresos se
tienen que conformar con una vivienda
asequible en el marco de planes
promovidos por la ciudad o por el estado
de nueva york o a vivir en un
apartamento de vivienda pública y
precisamente sobre esto
sobre lo que os vamos a hablar en este
vídeo vamos a analizar una de las
políticas públicas de vivienda más
grandes de todo el mundo en primer lugar
tenemos que conocer la diferencia entre
vivienda asequible y vivienda pública
la primera la vivienda asequible es
aquella que está sometida a algún
programa de subvenciones o
desgravaciones fiscales dirigidas a
reducir el precio de los alquileres
alquileres que suelen estar en
promociones de viviendas privadas
la segunda la vivienda pública es un
tipo de vivienda construida mantenida y
gestionada completamente por las
administraciones públicas es decir
viviendas en las que si por ejemplo se
te estropea la caldera o se avería el
ascensor un trabajador público es el
encargado de gestionar la incidencia y
solucionar la iese nueva york
precisamente donde se encuentra la mayor
administración de vivienda pública de
norteamérica la autoridad de la vivienda
de la ciudad de nueva york más conocida
como nacha por sus siglas en inglés
[Música]
la mancha fue creada en 1934 justo
después del famoso crack del 29 que
sumió la ciudad en una profunda crisis
económica y hundió en la pobreza a una
parte importante de la clase media de
aquella época
[Música]
debido a esta crisis muchos neoyorquinos
perdieron sus casas y se vieron forzados
a vivir en infraviviendas o hacinados en
pisos compartidos así que para
solucionar este problema el entonces
alcalde fidel o enrico o la guardia
fundó la night for mandato del estado de
nueva york un programa masivo de
vivienda pública ha gestionado
principalmente por el ayuntamiento de
nueva york pero cuyos recursos
económicos procedían sobre todo del
gobierno federal y de las propias rentas
de los inquilinos amigos esta iniciativa
empezó muy bien sin embargo lleva
décadas sufriendo muchos problemas la
inviabilidad financiera el surgimiento
de guetos y los graves problemas de
mantenimiento son sólo algunos ejemplos
y precisamente por eso en este vídeo te
vamos a hablar de cómo la joya el
orgullo de las políticas sociales de
nueva york se ha convertido hoy en una
de sus mayores vergüenzas esta es la
historia de uno de los grandes fracasos
de las políticas sociales de los eeuu de
américa
atentos
[Música]
un modelo exitoso durante un tiempo
en los años 30 el modelo de vivienda
pública experimentó un auge radical en
eeuu multitud de ciudades por todo el
país se implantaron prácticamente cada
día este tipo de políticas de vivienda
para responder a las consecuencias de la
crisis económica pero de todas ellas
nueva york fue sin duda alguna la que
más decididamente lo hizo en un
principio el programa consistió en
adquirir promociones inmobiliarias
inacabadas o quebradas por la crisis
promociones que luego la reciente
autoridad de la vivienda terminaba de
construir para albergar a gente con
problemas económicos a cambio de un
alquiler muy reducido ahora bien si
pensáis que el modelo estaba
inicialmente orientado a ayudar a los
más pobres no estáis muy equivocados de
hecho fue justo lo contrario la nacha
impidió a los residentes con ingresos
más bajos acceder a esta ayuda que
estaba en la práctica destinada a
rescatar por así decirlo a la clase
media que lo estaba pasando mal durante
la crisis
[Música]
más tarde en los años 50 y 60 se
estableció literalmente una lista de
factores morales que concienzudamente
excluían a los más pobres por ejemplo no
podían residir en este tipo de viviendas
personas con trabajos irregulares en su
historial de empleo problemas mentales
alcoholismo madres solteras o incluso
personas con faltas de muebles se
consideraba que estos factores
excluyentes permitirían preservar la
seguridad la salud y la moral de estas
nuevas comunidades recordad que estamos
hablando de un país donde todavía el
clasismo y el racismo estaban a la orden
del día de esta forma en la práctica
durante las primeras décadas de
funcionamiento de la nike sus
promociones estaban repletas de
residentes blancos las minorías raciales
se quedaron fuera
[Música]
está cómo decirlo marginación condenó
aún más a las minorías a la exclusión
social lo que a su vez alimentó la
delincuencia ya no es que no recibieran
ayuda sino que el sistema los excluyó
deliberadamente estos colectivos
tuvieron que recluirse en guetos tenían
menos acceso a los servicios públicos
que la ciudad concentraba en las zonas
consideradas como respetables
alimentándose así el rechazo social y
vuelta a empezar de hecho se considera
que este fue uno de los factores que
explican los graves problemas de crimen
y drogas que la ciudad tuvo durante las
décadas los 70 y los 80 pero no nos
desviemos
[Música]
la cuestión es que nos guste o no
excluir a todas estas personas y toque
vivir en una vivienda de la caixa fuera
incluso algo deseado al fin y al cabo
hablamos de complejos residenciales que
tienen en muchos casos mejores
condiciones de vida que muchas vidas
privadas de clase media pensad que
hablamos de viviendas nuevas y que
además contaban con servicios
comunitarios como servicios de
mantenimiento propios primeros auxilios
tiendas escuelas servicios de seguridad
tenían incluso jardines y zonas privadas
para aparcar algo poco frecuente en esa
época de mi época el personal eran lo
mejor tenían su trabajo hacían su
trabajo y estaban preparados para su
trabajo llamabas y te lo arreglaban de
inmediato y lingua que el residente de
las queens brits houses desde 1958 para
new york times' además la pasta que
llegaba del gobierno federal era
abundante así que los complejos
viviendas tenían un mantenimiento al día
que los inquilinos no tenían que
sufragar que se les estropeaba la
caldera no había problema llamaban y se
lo arreglaban que tenían una fuga en él
exactamente lo mismo que hacía falta
pintar faltaría más
dicho y hecho estos mejores tiempos
había 17.000 empleados a cargo de las
labores de mantenimiento de los cientos
de edificios residenciales públicos de
la ciudad de nueva york por tener tenían
incluso su propio cuerpo de policía con
2.700 agentes hasta que en el 95 se
integraron en la policía de nueva york
[Música]
en definitiva las condiciones de vida
hasta la década de los 60 eran incluso
mejores que las que la clase media podía
encontrar en el mercado privado y para
ese momento la nacha ya era el casero de
alrededor de medio millón de
neoyorquinos sin embargo durante los
sesenta con la mejora de las condiciones
de la clase media blanca y la
prosperidad que se vivía en el país fue
creciendo la presencia de minorías de
bajos ingresos que se mudaban a una
vivienda pública además en 1968 por la
presión del activismo y del propio
gobierno federal
nueva york- eliminó muchos de los
requisitos morales para acceder al
programa lo que aumentó aún más la
demanda
todo esto alimento un cambio en el
estilo de vivienda que se empezó a
construir de repente ese cambio el
modelo de bloques bajos y amplios
espacios verdes por enormes bloques de
unas 20 plantas para albergar a más y
más gente fueron desarrollos
urbanísticos' que ni siquiera estaban
bien insertados en el plano urbano la
prioridad ya no era garantizar un buen
nivel de vida sino sobre todo repartir
viviendas a cuantas más personas mejor
utilizadas por eso no me dieron bien las
consecuencias que este nuevo modelo
podría llegar a tener muchos urbanistas
consideran de hecho que el nuevo modelo
creó una tercera ciudad dentro de nueva
york- en la práctica lo que estaba
germinando era una división social que
terminaría por explotar justo en la
década siguiente en los 70 quieres
conocer cómo fue la caída en desgracia
del anaita pues atento
el punto de inflexión
la década de los 70 fue un punto y
aparte una década de muchos cambios en
los desarrollos residenciales públicos
de nueva york- los nuevos barrios de
vivienda pública no tenían locales
comerciales ni espacios para montar
negocios con lo que rápidamente se
convirtieron en zonas aisladas de las
dinámicas del resto de la ciudad esto
sumado a la marginalidad y a la
exclusión que sufría la comunidad negra
termine rápidamente por convertir las
nuevas moles de vivienda pública en
peligrosos guetos donde la criminalidad
y el vandalismo crecían sin parar
digamos que a muchas personas se les dio
una vivienda pero no un modo de vida y
una fuente de ingresos alternativa más
allá de las prestaciones de los
servicios sociales tampoco se estudiaron
los saltos culturales y se establecieron
planes para favorecer la inclusión de
las personas con más problemas no para
nada lo que se hizo fue mezclar a todo
tipo de personas generalmente negras con
circunstancias económicas y personales
muy distintas en unos bloques enormes
aislados de la ciudad fue
el caldo de cultivo perfecto para un
montón de problemas un ejemplo estos
barrios fueron los que más sufrieron la
epidemia del crack de los años 80 un
período durante el cual muchos
residentes utilizaron sus viviendas como
punto de venta y consumo de
estupefacientes pero esto no es todo
[Música]
junto a los cambios de orientación en
las políticas públicas se produjo otro
factor determinante para el progresivo
abandono de la vivienda pública
neoyorquina en 1978 se aprobó la ley de
vivienda y desarrollo comunitario
también conocida como sección 8 que creó
el programa de vales de elección de
vivienda este programa la práctica
implicó un cambio de política por el
cual el modelo de vivienda pública
construida gestionada y mantenida por
las administraciones públicas empezó a
ser sustituido por viviendas subsidiadas
en el mercado privado un modelo quizás
más eficaz para justo pero que claro
generó un recorte salvaje en los fondos
federales para la nacha que se
consideraba un modelo obsoleto y en
decadencia lo que rápidamente se tradujo
en una grave falta de mantenimiento de
las viviendas públicas y de los
edificios neoyorquinos para que os
hagáis una idea en la actualidad gran
parte de los dos mil cuatrocientos
sesenta y dos edificios de la lancha
presentan un estado de mantenimiento
propio del tercer mundo techos con
goteras cuando llueve constantes averías
en las viejas calderas en pleno invierno
ventanas rotas que tardan semanas y
meses en repararse cocinas que no
funcionan en fin la situación es tan
dramática que a día de hoy
en muchos de los edificios de la dicha
son así de duras hace poco no tuvimos
agua caliente durante tres días así que
no podías bañarte o ducharte miriam
woods residente del astoria house es en
queens desde 1996 para new york times' y
recordad que hablamos de una ciudad
donde las temperaturas pueden alcanzar
una media de menos 10 grados en invierno
[Música]
el problema es que la falta de fondos
generales no parece que vaya a
revertirse y digo problema porque se
calcula que la nada necesita
atentos al menos 31 mil 800 millones de
dólares en reparaciones una factura que
no deja de crecer de hecho se estima que
para 2027 el 90 por ciento de las
unidades de vivienda de la nacha habrán
llegado a un punto en el que sea más
barato demoler las y volverlas a
construir que repararlas si el sistema
público de vivienda de nueva york
terminó condenando a miles y miles de
personas a una vida cuasi marginal
rodeada de delincuencia estupefacientes
exclusión y carencias de todo tipo
amigos este es uno de esos casos en el
que el supuesto regalo terminó
convirtiéndose en un regalo envenenado y
claro la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es que solucionaría todo esto pues
atentos
se puede salvar la nacha
aún con todo y pensando en el futuro la
agencia de vivienda de nueva york tiene
dos grandes fortalezas no tiene deudas y
tiene un patrimonio enorme hablamos de
dos mil cuatrocientos sesenta y dos
edificios y más de diez kilómetros
cuadrados de terreno en una ciudad donde
podéis creerme él solo es carísimo sin
embargo también tiene dos debilidades
importantes primero la falta de
mantenimiento y abandono de los
inmuebles que ya os hemos contado y
segundo la escasez crónica de ingresos
los ingresos por las rentas y tarifas de
los inquilinos que pagan una media de
484 dólares al mes de alquiler sólo
cubren una tercera parte de los gastos
de la nacha el resto tiene que ser
subsidiado además también existe un
problema importante de impagos el 30% de
los pagos mensuales no se abonan
ahora bien el mayor problema para la
ciudad son los más de 30 mil millones
que se necesitan invertir en unos
edificios que se caen a pedazos y la
pregunta es existe alguna alternativa
[Música]
pues bien el actual alcalde bill de
blasio cree que si veréis de blasio ha
impulsado un plan a 10 años llamado next
generation con tres objetivos clave en
primer lugar conseguir reparar las
deficiencias de mantenimiento más graves
en segundo lugar reducir el
desequilibrio entre ingresos y gastos y
por último potenciar el modelo de vale
de vivienda que impulsó la sección 8
para conseguirlo primero de blasio
abierto la nacha a la colaboración
público-privada en el marco del programa
federal rat de modo que algunas de las
promociones están pasando a estar
gestionadas por empresas privadas en
otras palabras se ha comenzado a
externalizar la gestión y el
mantenimiento y de momento los
resultados no parecen nada malos son ya
casi 15.000 los apartamentos públicos de
nueva york que operan de forma privada
alrededor de un 9% del total y ojo que
esto es sólo el principio porque la idea
del plan es que termine habiendo 62 mil
viviendas bajo este sistema una tercera
parte del total ahora bien cómo va a
funcionar este nuevo modelo
pues bien una o varias empresas privadas
se encargarán de que esté un animal
tener los complejos de viviendas
transferidos por la nacha que eso sí
seguirá siendo su propietaria sin
embargo los inquilinos dejarán de pagar
su alquiler a la autoridad municipal y
pasarán a cerró a las empresas privadas
que deberán cumplir con el límite del
coste del alquiler que fija la ley para
la vivienda protegida además los
inquilinos que ya estaban bajo el modelo
anterior no podrán ser expulsados de sus
viviendas
y que se consigue a cambio pues esta
externalización está permitiendo la
renovación integral de promociones
enteras sin engordar tanto el gasto
público y de momento parece que los
inquilinos bajo este nuevo sistema ya lo
empiezan a notar el alcalde de vila se
anuncia que 62 mil apartamentos de la
nacha recibirá en reparaciones
integrales la novedosa asociación
público-privada dedicará casi 13 mil
millones de dólares para reparaciones de
primera necesidad los aproximadamente
140 mil residentes en estas unidades
conservarán todos sus derechos como
residentes de viviendas públicas pagarán
un alquiler limitado al 30 por ciento de
sus ingresos y permanecerán en sus
edificios durante las renovaciones que
incluirán cocinas y baños nuevos
sustitución de ventanas ascensores
calderas y techos y mejoras en zonas
comunes amigos amigas el modelo de
vivienda puramente pública ha fracasado
en nueva york' y la autoridad de la
vivienda de la ciudad podría convertirse
en un mero propietario que otorga
concesiones más que un gestor completo
de esta forma se supone que las empresas
privadas serán más activas a la hora de
exigir a los inquilinos que cuiden de
sus viviendas y serán
más eficientes con los gastos ahora bien
será todo esto suficiente eso luego no
parece una tarea sencilla pero sí que
puede ser una buena forma de empezar a
cambiar las cosas pensando un momento
vivir en un entorno abandonado y muy
degradado se convierte en un semillero
de problemas eso es exactamente lo que
parece decir la evidencia y los
experimentos que se han realizado así
que al menos desde ese punto de vista
aparecen unas noticias un primer paso o
mejor dicho un segundo paso el primer
paso fue reconocer el fracaso del
programa en cualquier caso lo que queda
claro es que no siempre las buenas
intenciones se terminan traduciendo en
buenas políticas cuidado con esas cosas
pero ahora turno para ti cuál crees que
es la mejor forma de reducir la
exclusión social entre los sectores más
desfavorecidos de la población urbana
déjanos por aquí abajo tus opiniones y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante
no olvides hacérnoslo saber dándole al
botón de like un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]